it says if you're unsure about your
relationship try asking yourself these
five honest questions they have
personally helped me so much one if
someone told you you're a lot like your
partner would this be a compliment to
you
two are you truly fulfilled or just less
lonely
three are you able to be
unapologetically yourself or do you feel
the need to show up differently to
please your partner
four are you in love with who your
partner is right now as a whole or are
you only another they're good side their
potential or the idea of them
and then five would you want your future
slash imagine child to date someone like
your partner